martin likes to make flower bouquets
that have that each have three violets
and four tulips
if the price of a violet is v and the
price of a tulip is t
match the expressions to their meanings
so see the price of one of martin's
bouquets
so one of martin's bouquets has three
violets and four
four tulips so the three violets are
going to cost three times the price of
the violet which is v so that's the cost
of the violet's 3v
and then the four tulips are going to
cost four times the price of a tulip so
it's four t so it's three v plus four t
so it's not this one let's see this one
right over here this is four t plus
three v so this is the price of four
tulips four times the price of a tulip
plus three times the price of a violet
the price of three of martin's bouquets
so it's essentially going to be three
times this quantity right over here this
is the price of one bouquet we want
three of them so it's going to be 3
times the quantity 4t plus 3v
and let's see if i were to actually
multiply this out 3 times 4t is 12t
and then plus 3 times 3v is 9v so this
is the same thing if i were to
distribute the 3 is 12t plus 9
v
well that's this right over here these
two are equivalent expressions and let's
see are any of these other things
equivalent no this is 3 times 3t plus 4v
so i'm going to put this in the not used
bucket
and then i have let's see 3v plus 2t
this is i'm going to put in the not used
bucket
not used bucket
and let's see this has
2v plus 4t plus v so if i were to
simplify this if i were to combine the
the v terms if i have two v's and i had
another v that's three v's plus four t
so this is actually the same thing as
the price of one of martin's bouquets so
you could view this as the price of two
violets plus the price of four tulips
plus another violet so it's really the
price of three violets and four tulips
let's check our answer we got it right